- "Does being touched-starved
affect your sleep?"
It certainly affects mine,
I love to be cuddled.
As a medical condition,
probably not though.
I've been reading my comment section.
You guys have had some good questions.
Let's get to it. Pee-woop!
Laney Shea: "Why do my
sunburns never turn into tans?"
Because sunburns shouldn't
be happening to you.
Shade, SPF.
What's probably happening is
you're actually burning your skin,
and then that superficial
layer ends up peeling off
'cause there's so much damage there,
and your body perhaps doesn't
form enough melanocytes.
that's what gives the skin color,
the melanin, the pigments on your skin.
And you may not be a person
who has that much melanin in your body.
That's okay, wear that
SPF, stay in the shade.
Maria Turta, Maria Turturiello,
Maria Turturiello. (sighs)
Maria Turturiello,
Turturiello, Maria Turturiello.
"Hi Mike, what is the difference
between a family doctor
and a pediatrician?"
Well, a family doctor is able
to treat patients of all ages,
whether they're 1 or 101,
pediatrician solely focuses on children.
Both are capable of taking care of kids.
I see patients who are a part
of the pediatric population all the time.
Vaccination visits, school physicals,
complaints, developmental delays.
You know, sometimes we need
to get specialists on board,
but that would be the
same with a pediatrician
'cause at the end of the
day we're generalists,
and specialists are specialists.
TheLannisterLion: "Can giving CPR
without a certificate
have legal consequences>"
Well, I think it varies state by state,
but generally speaking,
the Good Samaritan rule should apply.
That means if you're the only individual
and you don't have a certificate,
you can try and save that person's life.
Because the last thing we want
are people being afraid to help victims.
So I urge you, if someone collapses,
call for help right away,
and if they're unconscious, not breathing,
you don't feel a pulse, Get
those chest compressions going.
Remember to the tune of "Staying Alive."
That's all I'm gonna say
'cause I don't want to get demonetized.
royaltwilight: "I was
wondering about the phrase
'Banks open on Tuesdays,
folks,' and what it meant."
When you shoot against the
backboard of a basketball hoop,
that's called a bank shot.
When you play horse,
a game where you try to
match your opponent's shot,
you got to call bank or
backboard before you shoot
if you're gonna use the backboard
and then your opponent has match your shot
with the backboard.
So for me, 'cause I'm nice with it,
and I take a fade away
and hit the backboard,
I go "Banks open on Tuesdays,
folks," 'cause it's true there
and about the financial system, you know?
onto a non-sanitized surface
bad for your health chronically?"
Are we talking about the five-second rule?
'Cause I think bacteria,
when they see something
fall, they're like,
"Chill, chill, chill, five
seconds, we gotta relax."
Not true, it's already
gonna have bacteria on it.
Is that the end of the world?
Is it something I recommend? Probably not.
Even my friends who are doctors
do some absolutely atrocious stuff,
like drop a piece of chocolate
on the hospital floor
and then pick it up and eat it
and quote the five-second rule.
Please don't ever do that.
Do you know what's in the hospitals?
Multidrug-resistant organisms.
You do not want one of those
hanging around in your mouth.
That's right, I said mouth.
Francesca Simi: "Why is it
that when you take a bad fall
you feel nauseous and need to throw up?"
Well, first of all, it could
be that you got motion sick
from how heavy you took that fall.
Second, if you fell so hard
that you have a fracture,
you could also get nauseous.
That's one of the hallmark
signs of having a fracture.
I remember when I was on that
bunny slope on that snowboard
and I thought I was Shaun White, I fell.
I learned my lesson 'cause I got nauseous
'cause I broke my arm, my wrist.
"Do we have a Doctor Mike Discord?"
Well, yes we do.
Although it is invite-only if you sign up
to the Patreon for only $10 a month.
But that money is not
for me, it's not for Dan,
it's not for Sam, and it's not for Bear.
It's for any good cause
that we decide together
at the end of the month,
every single month.
So join now. Link below.
lonelyjashinist: "Are doctors trained
to notice signs of emotional abuse?"
Absolutely, not just emotional abuse,
physical abuse, elder abuse,
and child abuse as well.
For example, if I have
a very young patient
that's coming in for multiple fractures,
if we do a bone scan and we see fractures
that are different stages of healing,
that makes us wonder,
"Why is this child frequently
getting these injuries?"
Plenty of children like to be wild
and run around and fall and
trip, it's part of life.
That being said, if it's
consistently happening,
it could be a sign of
physical abuse or neglect,
which is another type of abuse
that's equally as important to notice.
Now, elder abuse is something
that's less talked about
but also very, very important.
There exists individuals
who are being kept alive,
being neglected, being taken advantage of
for perhaps financial gain.
For example, many elder individuals
will receive Social
Security, government checks,
retirement checks, and
some family members,
really, in a horrible way,
will try and take that
money away from them.
And instead of use it to give them care,
they pocket it and use it
for their own purposes.
It's really evil when it
happens it's devastating,
and we need the courts to step in.
Rick Cheese: "Does chocolate
really cause acne?"
First of all, Rick Cheese, great username.
To ask about chocolate?
Thought you'd be asking me about cheese.
I don't think we have proof
that chocolate directly causes acne.
Also, I don't think it's ever the case
that a single ingredient
or a single food can cause a problem
that's as complex as acne.
In general, when we looked
at research in the past,
what we've seen is those who
eat a high amount of chocolate
and this isn't just cacao
chocolate, dark chocolate.
This is chocolate with dairy, with sugar,
with a lot of high, refined
carbs in their caramel,
all this stuff, they were
more likely to get acne.
Now look, those people also
led more on healthy lifestyles,
they didn't sleep enough,
they had high stress levels,
so it's no surprise that they
had more experience with acne.
That being said, there
have been some small,
randomized controlled studies showing
that chocolate can have
an effect here and there.
But to villainize a
specific nutrient like that,
I just don't think we
have enough evidence.
What's really smart to
do if you have acne,
is to talk to your dermatologist
about all the things
that can be contributing to acne
and then narrow it down from there.
Very rarely it's gonna be due
to a single food like chocolate.
Like if a patient walks in
and they have very bad acne
and they tell me all the things
that are going on in their life,
I can't expect that I'm
just gonna tell them,
"Oh, cut out chocolate, you'll be fine."
It's not gonna be good medical advice.
There have been some
smaller studies that confirm
that chocolate has
pro-inflammatory effects,
that means effects that create
inflammation in your skin.
That can be something that
can contribute to acne.
Second, we've seen high
glycemic load diets.
That means you eat a specific
food, it spikes your insulin,
that's considered a high glycemic load.
That can sometimes cause an increase
in sebum production leading to acne.
Sebum is that oil your skin creates
and eventually or potentially
can block off pores.
But again, there's no direct tying
that if you eat dark chocolate,
that you will then experience acne.
I think it's more complex than that
and simplifying it to
food X causing disease Y,
hmm, don't have the evidence for it.
Lacie Morris: "Have you
ever been in a situation
where you had to feel a patient's abdomen,
but they had PTSD? (sighs)
No, I would say the closest thing
that I've had happened was
when I had to perform OMT,
which is osteopathic manipulative therapy,
on someone who was, I guess,
traumatized in the sexual sense
and part of what I do,
because they were experiencing neck pain,
was evaluating the neck.
And I really just went about it
as forthcoming as I could be.
Meaning, giving all the details
of what I was about to do before I did it.
That developed a layer of
trust with that patient,
and we just took it
slowly one step at a time.
And that sort of desensitization
really helped that patient a
lot as we had more encounters
and were able to get rid of her neck pain
and she's doing quite well now.
OneKi: "Is sleeping at night healthier
than sleeping during the day?
For example, if you work
night shifts or third shifts,
or does it simply depend
on how many hours you sleep at once?"
When we look back at evidence,
meaning look back at individuals
who live the life of
sleeping during the day
as opposed to at night,
and we compare them to
those who sleep at night
and work during the day,
we see better outcomes for those
who sleep properly at night,
matching our human circadian rhythm.
That being said, we don't
have great reasoning
for why this happens,
outside that it doesn't follow
your natural circadian rhythm,
and likely that because of
weekends and everything else,
you're gonna be shifting back and forth,
and that's really unhealthy.
My recommendation if I was giving it
to one of my family members would be
to try and find a career
where they can sleep at night
and work during the day.
But I know that's not
feasible for everybody.
I don't want you to worry about it
as if it's just this horrible thing.
Just know that is one
potential risk factor
that you can mitigate.
DIAMOND ON DEMAND: "I'm nearing 18 years."
Uh, midlife.
"Should I start watching for my eating?
Diabetes is common in
half my family line."
You should absolutely start looking
at what you're eating now
rather than waiting till later.
I'll explain why.
When we think about heart disease,
meaning people that get heart attacks,
their blood vessels
start getting blocked off
from plaque buildup within the arteries
within the blood vessels,
but that plaque doesn't
form when you're 40
or when you're 30.
I mean, it builds up during those ages,
but it really starts laying the foundation
at your age, at 18.
So if you can live a healthy life
and watch what you eat early on,
that's gonna pay dividends
when you're in your 30s,
40s, 50s, 60s, 70s, 80s,
90s, 100s, 110s, or 120s.
Check out these videos here
on the truth about picking your nose
or cracking your knuckles.
Arthritis? (chuckles)
Stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)